The man’s bedroom hadn’t been silent for
over 100 years now.
The carpet had been worn down, a thick layer
of dust had gathered on every surface, and
the same trapped air had stagnated for so
long that it had become unbearable for anyone
entering the room.
But no one was allowed to enter the room.
Nobody could open that door ever again, or
it could mark the beginning of not just an
apocalypse, but a breakdown in the nature
of reality itself.
Figures shuffled around the room.
Sometimes dozens, sometimes as few as three,
all rotting but never dying.
Researchers peered through the windows in
abject terror, day after day, as the laws
of physics broke down before their very eyes.
All of them except one, a lone scientist with
a plan to get inside that room.
A plan that the Foundation would shoot him
dead for.
A plan that he was seconds away from enacting
as the improvised explosive device in his
satchel clunked heavily against his thigh.
*
In many ways, we are just as trapped as SCP-001,
if not more so.
We are trapped in our own three-dimensional
world.
Take a stick figure drawn on a piece of paper.
That stick figure knows up and down, left
and right, that is their world.
You draw a box around them, and they are trapped,
unable to simply step forward out of the page
and walk around it.
For us, looking down at the stick figure,
we might laugh at their foolishness, trapped
inside a child’s drawing of a house.
It begs the question, is there a creature
looking down at us and laughing?
We may be able to move up and down, left and
right, forward and backward, outsmarting the
simple stick figure.
But in time, we are just as caged in, living
our entire lives on this razor-thin piece
of paper called the present.
The future is always just out of reach, the
past always repelling us, we have no choice
but to exist in the now, slowly creeping through
history without any agency of our own.
Cursed to be born, live, and die, in that
order.
You can never be a child again, never see
your mother’s face for the first time beaming
down at you.
You cannot skip ahead to your dying minutes,
know what it is you will have to face up to
in your life.
Maybe the idea of facing up to things at all
will fade with the freedom of exploring what
once was and what will be as if it were no
more difficult than taking a step out of a
2D box.
*
The bell rang, cutting Professor Davies off.
He hadn’t meant to go into such an existential
tangent, especially for his first-year students.
Most of them looked like they were in a daze,
not really listening to anything he’d been
saying.
Quantum mechanics sure was a complex topic
to cover in just one semester at university.
He’d spent his entire career trying to wrap
his head around it and still spent more of
his days with the same bored and confused
glaze over his eyes as the teenagers who made
their way to the back of the hall.
But one figure, standing just beyond the doorway,
peering down at him, caught the Professor’s
eye.
Little did he know how drastically his career
was about to change in just a few minutes.
A preeminent physicist at just 28 years old,
Professor Davies had already achieved the
status that many academics will not see within
their lifetimes.
Whenever anyone asked him about it, he always
made the joke that he was cheating.
He didn’t believe in the concept of a linear
lifetime in the first place.
Still too young to be taken seriously by many
of his peers, he had flown under the academic
radar for much of his career so far.
Perhaps it was as simple as that, or perhaps
certain undercover agents had a hand in suppressing
news of his blossoming career in quantum research.
*
His hands trembled as he approached the reinforced
glass.
He gripped the bag tightly, trying his best
not to let his fear show.
If any of them saw what he was about to do,
if they even suspected something, he’d have
a dozen bullets flying through the back of
his skull before he’d even have a chance
to put his hands up.
Shifting his weight from foot to foot, he
waited for the airlock to be opened for him.
A siren blared, red lights flashed, and the
first glass door slid open.
Stepping inside, he waited for the atmosphere
in the chamber to adjust.
Both doors were closed in front and behind
him.
If they wanted to kill him, now would be the
time.
He closed his eyes and waited with bated breath,
the bomb weighing heavily on his shoulder.
But they wouldn’t kill him.
He knew that now.
What he was about to do… was inevitable.
*
It took several months for Professor Davies
to be granted the full security clearance
he needed.
They kept referring to his project as a K-class
anomaly, whatever that meant.
In order to get him up to speed with the nature
of what he was to be working on, the Foundation
assigned him to various other SCPs first.
SCP-5027, 2821, 1887, any instance that had
some link to quantum mechanics or complex
theoretical physics.
They wouldn’t even tell him which SCP he
was being trained up to work on until one
morning when a team of agents was waiting
for him at the door to his quarters.
He wasn’t allowed to bring a bag or any
personal possessions.
Standard-issue clothing, a toothbrush, and
everything else he needed would all be provided
for him.
It was only then they told him which SCP he
was being assigned to.
SCP-001.
He was blindfolded for the entirety of the
journey.
Car, then plane, then another car, it was
a full 10 hours before his blindfold was removed
and his new project was revealed to him.
Professor Davies found himself in Site 01.
The place where all of this started, all the
SCPs, all the research, the secrecy, the assassinations,
the deaths of countless innocent people, and
an equal number of guilty parties.
It all started right here, Site 01.
The site itself resembled a large sarcophagus,
similar to the one found covering the Chernobyl
nuclear power plant - where do you think the
soviets got the blueprints for that from?
Everything in the room is arranged in a circle
around the center.
Research desks, maintenance equipment, raw
materials including a stockpile of wooden
planks and reinforced metal sheets, monitoring
equipment, security cameras, and of course,
some of the most advanced automatic weapons
systems in the world.
All pointed at a great glass box in the middle
of the hangar.
Measuring 30m in each direction, the glass
was 50cm thick, even all those high-caliber
weapons would have had a hard time creating
a chip in that.
But it wasn’t the glass box itself that
was so interesting, it was what was trapped
inside it.
A house inside a perfectly round glass bowl,
with no entrances or exits.
Complete with a front lawn, sidewalk, porch,
and even a tree in the backyard.
A regular American house, trapped in a box
like some kind of science experiment.
There was some kind of transparent airlock
system at the entrance.
On the other side of that was just a normal
walk up the garden path to the edge of the
second glass bubble enclosing the house.
But on closer inspection, Professor Davies
realized that it wasn’t actually your typical
American house at all.
The street lamp wasn’t electric.
It was made of iron with little glass-paned
windows.
An oil lamp?
In fact, the house did look odd to him.
There was no electric doorbell, but instead,
an actual physical bell system.
The whole house looked out of place, not just
because it was in a box in the central hangar
of a 42,000-ton sarcophagus, but because it
was from another era entirely.
You see, Site 01 was constructed around this
house.
The glass box and bubble, the sarcophagus,
all of it was built around the already existing
building.
Beneath the foundations, a hundred meters
beneath the surface, is an immense metal plate
that forms a perfect seal with the defenses
up top.
The only way in and out of Site 01 is through
an immense reinforced door.
But even all of these defenses will prove
utterly futile if anyone ever opens the thin
wooden door to the bedroom on the top floor
of the house.
That is the home and the prison in which SCP-001
is trapped.
It is the job of the Foundation to make sure
that it remains trapped there indefinitely.
What is SCP-001?
As Professor Davies made his way through the
airlock for the very first time and entered
the site under the supervision of four of
the highest-ranking SCP staff alive today,
he laid eyes on the entity itself for the
first time.
Standing on a scissor lift parked outside
the front of the house, just inches away from
the glass bubble, he was lifted high enough
to look through the window into what looked
like a young boy’s bedroom on the top floor.
Layers of dust coated the surfaces, black
and white photos sat in frames, antique children’s
toys sat all around the walls, but Davies
didn’t notice any of them.
He was too busy watching the men walking in
all directions.
Unhurried but with purpose, well over a dozen
men walked in all directions across the carpeted
floor.
They were all identical, around 6ft, with
heavy rotting skin that seemed to hang off
their limbs like it would a carcass left in
the sun.
Human cadavers, milling about in a young boy’s
bedroom.
Davies was so taken aback by their appearance
and behavior that it took him a long time
to notice something truly strange, the reason
he was brought here in the first place.
They were walking through the bed in the middle
of the room.
Not just over it or around it, but straight
through it as if it wasn’t there.
But wait, something else was wrong too, there
weren’t 12 of them in the room.
It was closer to 20.
Had he miscounted a moment ago?
Then he saw it take place.
One of the cadavers reached the edge of the
room and paused, as if in thought, at that
moment it split.
Not in half, but rather two versions of itself
emerged from where one had been standing,
both walking in different directions.
A thrill of excitement ran through Professor
Davies’ body.
The uncertainty principle.
It was there in action in front of him.
He was looking at Shroedinger’s cat inside
the box and seeing both its corpse and its
living self.
Where uncertainty exists, this entity was
somehow embodying both possibilities in real-time.
He watched the two selves walk around the
room, following different paths for several
minutes until eventually they converged again
back into one being.
He turned to the researcher accompanying him,
lit up with excitement, and asked what they
were doing in there.
The researcher’s face was grim when he replied.
They’re pacing…
Waiting.
*
The airlock door hissed open.
He felt the stale 1800s air hitting his face,
perfectly maintained at 20 degrees.
In front of him was just the garden path,
leading up to his goal.
That glass bubble.
Gripping the satchel, he set off up the path
slow enough not to attract any unwarranted
attention.
*
Over the next few days, Professor Davies learned
everything that the Foundation had on SCP-001.
It had been a human, once: a radical physicist
born in the late 19th century.
Intent on kickstarting the next century with
a nuclear renaissance, the young man had created
a working model for stable nuclear fusion.
The potential ramifications were enormous,
free clean electricity on a mass scale with
no harmful byproducts.
His research was almost complete when a covert
private military group poisoned him with his
own radioactive nuclear agent.
The young man made it back to his house, where
he died in his sleep that night.
Powerful military personnel and prominent
scientists who had been working alongside
the young man knew immediately what had happened.
Bursting into his home, they were about to
walk through his bedroom door and save him…
when they saw the shadow of two feet standing
by the door.
Then another pair.
The young scientist had died.
But he also hadn’t.
Much like Schrodinger's Cat, the man was suspended
in a dual state of death and not-death.
This shocking discovery led the group of people
present to form a rudimentary Foundation,
established to secure and contain their once
friend within his room, never to be discovered
by the wider world.
Through close observation since this time,
it has been established that SCP-001 exists
independently of linear time, in a kind of
superposition relative to the world around
it.
It is capable of occupying any space that
will or has been empty at any point in time.
Say you have two chairs in a room.
One chair has always been there, the other
was added to the room just five minutes before.
The SCP is unable to walk through the chair
that was always there since it has always
existed.
But the chair that was added can be passed
through with no problem, because there was
a point in time when that chair had not been
there.
But it also works in the future.
If a third chair was present, which had always
been there but was removed five minutes after
the experiment, SCP-001 could pass through
that chair also.
The Foundation theorizes - and hopes - that
the start of this ‘clock’ that SCP-001
operates on was the point at which the young
scientist died and did not die.
That is why it is incapable of escaping its
bedroom.
And that is why it is of vital importance
that the bedroom door remains closed, forever.
Ongoing maintenance work and preservation
techniques are being employed to keep the
house in as stable a state as possible.
Should anything happen to damage the integrity
of the structure, the quantum chaos contained
in that space could lead to a total breakdown
of the laws of physics, destroying not just
the world but the fundamentals of mathematics
as we know them.
*
The bomb bumped against Professor Davies’
thigh as he walked up to the house.
An old man whose life had been devoted to
denying the world its future.
A reality where what is and what could be
are just as real as one another.
A world where the pain of living in the now
fades, where you can travel to any moment
in your life and relive its joy.
Where you aren’t trapped by the aging process.
Infinite renewable energy to solve the world’s
problems.
A chance to see your deceased loved ones again.
A way to look at the universe through the
eyes of God.
The head of 001 containment, he had spent
his entire career overriding all of the safeguards,
tweaking containment rules just enough each
year, all so he could walk across this grass,
with a satchel on his shoulder, and an explosive
more important than the atomic bomb at his
hip.
He approached the glass of the inner sphere.
If he had done the math right, this should
do just enough damage to create a hole in
the containment structure.
The pressure change wouldn’t be too great
inside, but should be just enough to blow,
say, a bedroom door wide open…
Now check out “Insane SCP-001 Fight - Gate
Guardian VS Scarlet King” and “SCP-001
- The Gate Guardian!”